chantal hébert altier rage michel sauget
bonsoir bonsoir
alors michel si je commence avec vous
est ce que quelqu'un voulait vraiment
aller en élection je rappelle pour les
gens qui n'étaient pas avec nous au
début d'émission
cette fois ci la menace électorale est
écartée parce que le npd a voté contre
cette motion déposée par les
conservateurs alors est-ce que quelques
voulais vraiment y aller michel sid
après je pense que les libéraux auraient
pas ici est ce que c'est vous voulez
vraiment un échelon plus bas mais ils
ont pris le risque de ceux de ce vote de
confiance live ils en ont fait un vote
de confiance donc était prête à des
élections si ça devait tourner comme ça
mais peut-être qu'il n'était pas encore
prêt à en assumer la décision alors à
porter l'odieux faire une une élection
quelque part au mois de novembre
probablement avec une pandémie des deux
coaches entre m le tirage avait certains
libéraux est révolu à l'ena lecteurs il
y en avait d'autres que tu aimes suis
plus anxieux surtout aux raies les
députés je vais le député qui m'ont volé
mes stagiaires
est ce que vous pensez qu faveur
d'élections c'est quoi mais je vais vous
avait déjà des entrevues en avait en
français tous les matins en espaçant
deux radios à travers le pays qui fait
donne toujours une note d'encouragement
un remerciement aux candidats et aux
députés libéraux qui sont dans les
endroits à l'audience a acquis et se
dirige à lui je pense qu'ils en avaient
pas mal a bercé mort de ce qui se
passait dans un ensemble qui voulait
envoyer un message que les sources déjà
offert de très près hellip il y en a la
maison était vraiment comme elle elle
est trop loin il fallait aller plus t on
là pour les remèdes bamba chantal êtes
vous d'accord avec ce que c'est la
nature de la motion déposée par les
conservateurs qui a donné une occasion à
monsieur trudeau dire belloche a fait le
même genre peut se transformer en un
tapis ou c'est plus profond il ya
peut-être un désir
d'aller en élections selon un mélange
des deux je suis d'accord avec à
l'intérieur que tous les libéraux ne
voulait pas aller en campagne
certains libéraux je pense que dans
certains il y avait justin trudeau qui
nécessairement voulait partir mais qui
envoyait un signal assez clair que ça
dérange et ce à quoi on assiste ici à un
peu à une bataille et sur qui va diriger
cette chambre des communes le
gouvernement minoritaire ou l'opposition
dirigée par des conservateurs
je pense que au total le gouvernement
est probablement arrivé à ses fins
d'autre part à établir une trame
narrative qui dit en gros si le
parlement et pourrait être paralysée par
des histoires qui franchement ont pas
notre affaire
mais on a maintenant établie pourquoi ce
serait un vote de confiance dans notre
esprit tenez vous le pour dit vrai et
dernier point je pense que monsieur
trudeau la tuque ont emprunté beaucoup
plus à l'ingestion d'une chambre des
communes où il est minoritaire stephen
harper capal martin qui rappelez-vous
c'était mieux presque à quatre pattes
devant le npd qui avait convaincu bien
de ce projet qui doit traverser devenir
ministre dans son conseil des ministres
pour éviter justement perdre un vote de
confiance
plus de peur que de martin ce qu'on a vu
cette semaine chantal à la raison parce
que les libéraux n'ont pas négocié du
tout avec les alpinistes et le npd
qu'ils ont décidé dès qu'on s'en va pas
négocier pas vraiment avec le npd non
plus il n'y avait pas y avait pas
amender la motion comme le npd il
voulait alors on va s'arranger pour
incarner
mais les libéraux ils ont absolument
rien donné des libéraux
ils voient que peut-être l'image d'un
gouvernement majoritaire c'est peut-être
aux horizons une année prochaine le
budget la bête d'un trillion de dollars
le rappeur du commissaire à l'éthique au
sujet de la sphère unis le problème qui
s'en vient en 2021 sommes alors en
vérité insisté si il ya un bon moment
pour y aller
4 e mail bon alors mais chassez alors
justement alliant le dit il fallait que
jack médecine explique pourquoi il
allait entre guillemets sauver le
gouvernement en tout cas éviter les
élections
et est-ce qu'on avait mal pour lui ou
est-ce que c'est comment il s'était
borné d'après vous qui l'a pas fait la
preuve qu'il était chef extraordinaire
aujourd'hui c'est un bel euphémisme
parce que écouter ils arrivent en disant
je suis contre gouvernement je vais
voter avec le gouvernement et je n'ai
rien obtenu pour ça au moins les chefs
précédent du npd car dans des situations
similaires pouvait dire j'ai obtenu
telle chose qui fait partie des demandes
traditionnelles du npd ça c'est ce que
notre base veut on a au moins obtenu sa
là il a voté quand il ya haute et avec
le gouvernement indien qui étaient
copiées série alors lui qui est déjà pas
un chef avec autant d'ascendant sur son
caucus qu'on peut le penser c'est qu'il
sait pas et dès aujourd'hui pour sa
chatte âgée
il n'est pas arrivé en disant j'ai
obtenu ceci cela paie en échange je vais
poursuivre mais allez-y chanteur c'est
difficile d'avoir mal qu'on trouve parce
que avant même souvent je fais de
l'armée oui beaucoup
le problème de monsieur singh sait aussi
qu'ils pouvaient pas vraiment développer
sa thèse qu'on ne devrait pas avoir une
élection en pleine pandémie alors que
son principal partenaire en
colombie-britannique le premier
et encore je voulais y aller on va
l'écouter on va l'écouter
jack mais si on va voter contre
l'élection on ne donne pas une excuse au
premier ministre et justin trudeau de
déclencher une élection on va continuer
de faire le travail qu'il faut faire on
sait que les gens monsieur madame tout
le monde ont besoin des deux et c'est le
cas que les libéraux ne veut pas
continuer avec les conversations les
négociations et ça ne me dérange pas
parce que on a des autres inutile on va
confier les faire le travail du
parlement
on a des gîtes i dans les autres comités
bon je vous fais entendre également que
ça vient d'arriver c'est donc après le
vote
monsieur rodrigues on attend la réaction
des conservateurs
monsieur deltell mon âme sur le terrain
qu'est ce qu'on va écouter le parlement
a choisi les canadiens plutôt que la
petite politique
ce sont des moments avec beaucoup de
stress mais en même temps c'est une
certaine façon le propre d'un
gouvernement minoritaire
la menace cocistes est entièrement
provoquée par le geste irresponsable
posées par des conservateurs à ce qui a
trait au comité on n'a pas eu de
discussions depuis j'ai parlé de répit
dans tantôt avec monsieur deltell des
conservateurs pour lui dire qu'on était
tout à fait ouvert à poursuivre les
discussions là-dessus
j'attends le retour d'appel du parquet
ce qu'à penser à des choses qui va
discuter
c'est quand même extraordinaire ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui là on voit que
le npd arrête pas d crier sur tous les
toits que ce gouvernement là ne mérite
pas la confiance parce que ils ont uvré
de façon douteuse en reach out et ainsi
de suite
mais lorsqu'il ya un vote de confiance
décident de voter avec le gouvernement
oui c'est leur chien de poche
halak était déçu chatel de ne pas partir
en campagne électorale
oui je suis pas convaincu nécessairement
que le bloc veut partir mais en
regardant les sondages je pense que la
faiblesse des conservateurs au québec
qui pourrait diviser le vote non
libérale je pense que c'est le parti qui
avait moins de raisons de s'en inquiéter
chez les députés libéraux s'étaient
partagé de façon régionale c'est à dire
que si vous étiez un député de l'ontario
et de la colombie-britannique les 500
c'est bon ou dans le canada atlantique
pour lille bo1 députés québécois libéral
élu à l'extérieur de la grande région de
montréal
moins évident pour des raisons dont on
trouve que ce serait possible
ça veut dire que c'est pas très bien
quand les députés libéraux qui aurait
besoin que les conservateurs soient un
petit peu plus fort peut-être au québec
pour diviser le vote contre uc
exactement celle ci le vlok actuellement
serait très heureux de partir à la
campagne ça lui donnerait au moins deux
ulta kg maintenant mais si on donne du
temps au tour de se faire connaître au
québec il ya pas de personnes trop
mauvaise personnalité son français est
déjà bien meilleur que celui de son
prédécesseur
c'est là que ça peut faire mal dans la
région de québec entre autres aux
quelques blocs est ce que l'oeil tout ça
alors c'est le boulot qui avait le plus
de bonheur à aller en élections à ce
moment ci c'est pas arrivé
ce kyste aux conservateurs mais de bâtir
à partir de ça au québec ce qui peut
évidemment clip bon mais pendant gens
des conservateurs mais parlez moi j'ai
besoin de vos lumières sur ce comité
qu'il voulait créer sur wii et charité
toute cette histoire là il ya le ya une
enquête qu'on va avoir peut-être avant
la prochaine campagne peut-être pas du
commissaire à l'éthique celle enquête
qu'on attend le plus est-ce que ce
comité là c'était une partie page pour
voir ce que les libéraux étaient faibles
appelé l ai dit oui ou pas comment vous
voyez cette manoeuvre
du parti conservateur al tir c'est un
comité qui est pas mal
exceptionnel alors ce serait spécial la
majorité des options que président que
sera conservateur
le comité se donne le droit d'appeler le
premier ministre les messages
la nsa finances a mené sa santé n'est
pas honteux quand ça leur temps ils
pourraient passer trois heures avec
justin trudeau
aujourd'hui trois heures avec cet os
demain alors vous c'est pas surprenant
pourquoi les libéraux ils voulaient pas
ça du tout en plus elle ce n'est pas
juste la famille nie ces faits aussi
l'argent que les libéraux avaient donné
avec qui il avait des contacts libéral
dont 5 bis et les libéraux ont donné un
contrat de plus de 100 millions $ à
cette folie pour fait des ventilateurs
c'est un ancien des fixes étaient pas
prêts à les emmener large
il s'attaquait ou au mari de la chef de
cabinet du ministre l'accusant d'avoir
fait du lobbying de manière correcte
mais ici comme cela et il y avait du nom
personnel et fait partir c'est une
expression en anglais
steenbergen sévit dans un baggy qui est
un poisson c'était un peu le concept ce
que nous dit on peut comprendre que
quelque part les libéraux se sont dits
ou en tout cas monsieur trudeau je pense
que j'aimerais mieux quatre prochaines
semaines avoir mis ministre se faire
convoquer à droite à gauche mon
personnel par ce genre de comité doit
selon moi c'était pas non plus la
meilleure idée des conservateurs dans le
sens où j'ai l'impression que c'est
peut-être que je suis complètement à
côté de la track nommé j'ai l'impression
que se donnent les conservateurs ont
vraiment besoin c'est de se présenter
comme monsieur autour d'eux le dis
souvent comme un gouvernement de
rechange une le prochain gouvernement en
attente et toute cette énergie sur wit
réalité dont on ne parle pas beaucoup
dans le passé dans les rues de montréal
de québec où ton tout ça donne
l'impression encore une fois qu'on est
en train de passer une audition pour
être position
est-ce qu'il ya encore du millage à fond
on verra ce que dans le rapport du
commissaire à l'éthique la tumeur est
encore du millage à faire tant que ça
sur wii charity pour les oppositions moi
je vois pas beaucoup beaucoup de millage
affaire où comme vous dites on verra le
rapport mais à la fin ceux qui avaient à
sortir est sorti est bon c'est pas de
faire d'elle des commandites cette
affaire là c'est pas quelque chose qui
qui montre un système de corruption
organisée au plus haut niveau du
gouvernement
ils ont on a été un peu trop gentil avec
une oeuvre de bienfaisance qui est un
peu douteuse d'ailleurs mais c'est
police pas la fin du monde alors je
pense pas dans la rue comme c'est
chantal la québec à montréal ou à
toronto les gens se frottent se tape le
front faisant au putsch charité ce cbl
ouais elle tient c'est ce que ça
concourt à créer une espèce de distance
entre ce que ce dont on débat à la
chambre des communes et la réalité des
gens quand ils regardent du sol je pense
que je pense la personne qui avait l'air
le plus soulagé aujourd'hui franchement
c'était au tour les confondateurs ils
ont besoin d'aller chercher du monde qui
naissent ils ne font pas déjà partie de
leur base
puis tout est affaire de qualité sur
wistra unis ce roi absolu c'est à dire
juste rejoindre leurs bases les gens à
l'extérieur d'ottawa
les partisans n'ont pas ou pas de savoir
si cette salle est tellement simple
tellement de ressources je sais que
gouvernante souvent mais c'est vrai ça
prend du temps s'organiser ça veut tout
le gouvernement doit s'occuper de ce
problème partisan à la au lieu de faire
leurs devoirs alors les députés avaient
raison mais le gouvernement leur tube à
essai pas au seul argument c'est un
argument très bien dernier tour de table
vous nous dites vous trois là dessus où
vous êtes d'accord vous nous dites
n'aurait pas détesté se soude ou
d'enfants 21 voix
est ce à dire qu'il pourrait aller s'ils
voient que le parlement marche pas ça à
sa guise chantal est ce à dire qu'il
pourrait lui même se donner la mort
d'ici noël
ou bien le scénario du printemps reste
le plus vraisemblable d'abord l'argument
d'une campagne électorale en cas de
pandémie
ça a pas porté malchance au nouveau
brunswick au gouvernement sortant de la
colombie britannique qui ont déclenché
des élections qui ont peu été défaits
pour le faire et des stratèges libéraux
qui vont vous dire on est mieux d'aller
en campagne électorale en pandémie
pendant que les gens apprécient encore
notre aide plutôt qu'une fois qu'elle
est passée qui vont regarder les
factures ce qu'est un premier problème
deuxièmement oui moi je crois que si
l'opposition va pas passer pas fini
cette histoire de comités de sa samba
dans un autre comité et en os mais là
c'est pour ça que je parlais de
promeneurs hâtives monsieur trudeau a
établi une trame narrative qui lui
permettrait hypothétique de d'aller voir
la gouverneure générale on nous a
écoutés on a fait notre possible mais de
toute évidence ces gens là n'étaient pas
au sérieux ils veulent pas travailler
avec nous et il faut qu'on gagne ça mon
impression à moi c'est non seulement
justin trudeau seraient pas fâchés des
liens campagne électorale cet automne
mais qu'à la fin c'est pas son but de
perdre mais c'est hyper désherber que
quelqu'un d'autres s'essayent à gérer
tout ça elle tient là dessus je suis
d'accord cintres donnerai pas détesté ça
du tout je pense pas qu'on va avoir une
élection au printemps par contre ce que
je pense qu'ils ont reçus leur demande
alors ils vont découvrir que leurs
chèques étaient imposables et pas juste
que la dette est énorme
de plus je pense que si le gouvernement
fait fi et un autre 6 8 mois ce serait
beaucoup plus c'est ce qu'a à leur
avantage aliette à l'automne prochain ou
même d'aller les quatre ans au total
mais je pensais qu est ce que le dow a
fait cette semaine c'est que de
l'opposition
je suis prêt à aller voir la gouvernance
générale jb être presque n'importe quoi
alors essayé moi j'ai changé pour cette
fenêtre si elle en a eu il reste presque
[ __ ] le temps minimum de ngarba
électorale au canada ces cinq semaines
au milieu mais pau souvenez-vous du tout
les mêmes circonstances
si on est obligé oui mais je pense que
le prétend peut-être au printemps pour
pas qu'on soit dans des fêtes budgétaire
ce sera ce serait possible mais sinon ça
fait un an aujourd'hui jour pour jour on
était en soirée électorale cette
heure-ci les revenants comme elle
l'aurait cru salut merci des très bons
merci c'est très éclairant poussins au
revoir à la prochains mois merci pas de
paris